sony pictures released the first
official trailer for the next entry in
the marvel cinematic universe's
spider-man series spider-man no way home
the trailer revealed glimpses of what is
to come in the life of peter parker
following the events of his last film
spider-man far from home as peter deals
with the ramifications of having his
secret identity revealed to the world he
turns to doctor strange for help hoping
the sorcerer's supreme has a spell to
undo what mysterio did in the last film
predictably the spell goes horribly awry
and peter is left to contend with a slew
of new villains and challenges as the
multiverse seemingly falls apart around
him the trailer hadn't been released for
even a day before people began picking
it apart in true mcu fashion for those
looking to pick a bit more than others
there's something about doctor strange
that has many fans suspicious of the
wizard could there be more than meets
the
uh i when it comes to this multiversal
magician the speculation surrounding
doctor strange kicked off with a twitter
thread made by the great boss logic
saying i for one think that doctor
strange is suspect especially since we
are getting introduced to the dark
doctor in what if probably a stretch but
he looks us before long people began
commenting on the post sharing what
aspects of doctor strange seemed a bit
off in this trailer one reply added i
honestly wouldn't be surprised to find
out that steven has been in control of
everything the entire movie and that
he's just teaching peter a lesson
because my dude was quick to use a
dangerous reality altering spell for
little to no reason plenty of other
characters in the marvel universe can
mess with the multiverse most notably
mephisto who did precisely that in the
one more day comic storyline on top of
strange's seemingly out of character use
of a dangerous spell one user noticed
that this doctor strange still has the
eye of agamotto in the trailer despite
the artifact getting destroyed by thanos
in avengers infinity war unless the
strange we know rebuilt it without the
time stone this might indicate some
multiversal interference from another
strange the movie may explain why he has
another infinity stone after all there's
like 11 of those sitting around in the
time variance authority desk drawers
there's another theory about doctor
strange from twitter that really puts a
twist on the character he does seem to
be gunning for peter in parts of the
trailer multiplying the trains in what
looks like a face-off plus the other
mirror dimension-like scenes plus the
aggressive way he's forcing peter's
astral form to leave his body if that is
true then this film may see strange
become a villain the reason why however
is anyone's guess there's another way
that the good doctor might not be a good
doctor at all screen rant features
editor alicia grouso writes everyone
saying dr strange doing the spell even
though it was dangerous seems out of
character apparently forgot that steven
strange's foundation in the mcu is
arrogance and the desire to test limits
basically if doctor strange isn't a
villain maybe he's just a jerk granted
he seemed more subdued in infinity war
and endgame but perhaps tony stark's
death had a profound impact on him it's
possible strange recognizes that peter's
identity being known to the world puts
his life as well as the safety of his
loved ones in jeopardy he may be more
willing to bend the rules a little bit
if it means he can save another avengers
life another factor worth bearing in
mind is that the mcu spider-man trailers
have a habit of bending the truth a
little bit this most notably occurred
with the spider-man homecoming trailer
which included a shot of iron man and
spider-man going through new york city
together it became an iconic moment but
it's nowhere to be found in the film
itself that's just one of the many lies
the mcu has told in trailers it's
possible doctor strange's willingness to
mess with the space-time continuum was
edited for trailer purposes to make the
story cleaner we could find something
entirely different once the film
releases on december 17 2021 check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about spider-man
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one